Creating sites and scans in Enterprise should be easy.
Are you confused by the sheer volume of site settings?
Do you suffer choice paralysis when viewing scan configurations?
Do your scans seem to take forever?
Introducing new washing machine style configurations from Burp Suite.
A revamped scan settings area helps you to reduce cognitive load with four brand new purpose
built configurations to help you run scans much more easily.
See results in 15 minutes with lightweight mode.
Get a little bit more thorough with results in an hour in fast mode.
Freshen up your scanning in balance mode, the perfect cycle for coverage and speed.
And finally, wash away those hard to find issues with DeepScan.
Still need other configurations from the library? No problem!
Just choose custom configurations and select from the drop down list available.
Now it's much more easy to create scans in Enterprise.
Washing machine configurations will be available in Burp Suite Enterprise from June.
One more yet.
I think you know what's coming.
When running scans in Burp Suite Enterprise, do you ever simply wonder what is the scanner doing?
Are you frustrated by the lack of information available?
Do you find it hard to fix issues when scans fail?
Do you find it hard to find out?
Any questions?
No, no questions.
You find a box big enough to fit this,
and I will dress up as a washing machine next time.
But until then, thank you very much.